can i just take a second to share my
notes for this uh this episode of the
podcast yes
yes
perfection erotic ideal
wow that was just what wow there we go
it really was yeah i got to we should do
i have uh we have many more hours you
know you have to come you have to come
back because my
time with you is
serious i'm going to be sincere and it's
hard for me to do that uh but
you're one of my favorite people you
really are
and um
i just absolutely love talking to you
and
it is whenever we're together whether
it's been on the show or this podcast um
it is unlike any other experience i have
and it means a lot to me and so when i
heard that
that you were going to come in and
inaugurate our new studio uh my head
blew up it exploded well me too i've
been looking forward to this
terrifically and uh
these are my favorite these are peak
experiences for me and people come up to
me on the street anecdotally and say
you on conan you and conan you and conan
see we got to do something they do well
i think so too i've been screen tested
and apparently it's not good
uh it won't be a film but maybe an
animated project something where my face
is mostly hidden
and you're singing authentically a lot i
like that um
the um and i just saw a um a documentary
about or some kind of
thing about talk show the history of
talk shows and the current yeah did you
see this one there i don't know i don't
watch them i love them all and this one
particularly said here's why
amongst the current crop in the last in
the last few decades
conan o'brien reigns supreme he's
cracked the code and why he's at the
pinnacle of what this needs to be right
now now et cetera et cetera yeah well
yeah i know
now i'm not uncomfortable i just don't
believe that that exists they're talking
about this conan o'brien
and he makes a
this guy game a very good case for
exactly why it's a very erudite and
there's a guy named conrad o'ryan
in dublin who's huge
and he's really cracked the code that's
very cool well it's true it's true it's
true well jeff and you all together i
mean i'm really starting struck with all
of you
you pronounce my name
i i there should be a a a perfume not
obsession but more yes
i'm wearing
how do you say what's that vowel exactly
is it gore gore like gore like gore
yeah although when i went to ireland
they said it's girly ah girl
is it really yeah
well they were just saying you seem kind
of girl yeah i think so that's cool
i said it's gorillas no it's
along with you know i've seen every
single schlansky uh oh my god every
single schlansky
really
really
i laugh out ideas over and over again i
see them multiple times and it's all
true that's the one thing i've been in
i've been in the darkest regions darkest
most remote corners of the world and
people will
literally come out from behind a rock
and say
schlansky yeah is he being real
i'll go yes he's being real then they go
back under the rock you're never funnier
when when he's driving you mad it's just
great oh my god well i gotta get it back
you know what i could go on uh mr
goldblum mr jeff goldblum you're the
finest man that ever lived conan
christopher o'brien oh my god yes you
were the finest man
yeah sorry you're better i'm taking you
to a sizzler
let's go
langustino